what I asked someone yeah but that time
is it hmm
y'all can help me out on this one my
question is why on earth would you vote
me out I didn't vote you out because I
was HOH and if I was had a vote I want
to vote you you're my boy was I really
that big of a threat Ryan
bro apparently you me and Jonathan were
perceived as big huge threats I'm
joining you now outside so we share that
same title of either not being liked or
being perceived as a big threat we can
tell ourselves this because we're big
threats all right let's just call it
that I have no idea who do you think is
the most dishonest person in the house
the most dishonest person the house is
can we tie with three people
it's Ricky Ricky is the most dishonest
person in the house all right he told me
he played football in the NFL why that
like he did Oh Natalie all the people
that voted against me five of those
people Oh so who's making the coffee now
thank you
I made it every morning every morning
Cato nutmeg cinnamon and pumpkin spice
and no one even okay yikes
um since I don't drink coffee anymore I
believe Tom or Deena is making the
coffee now I think Tom don't you think
you and I should be on a CBS sitcom
together yes or no Natalie
absolutely you've got to be a superhero
though a purple haired superhero yeah
I'll just say hey welcome to the outside
world I had so much fun hanging out with
you I'm glad to be back I can't wait to
get in my bed and I'm looking forward to
the rest of my life who in the house
touched you the most deeply I was
touched by everyone how many games of
gin rummy did she beat me at Oh
a hundred at least will she get on the
group get on a group text text with
everyone from the cast she said no but
now that they voted for her and
unanimous will she go ahead and be on a
group text with everybody I'm gonna have
to pray about that because I think other
people's gonna text more than others but
I will include our in our bedroom chat
about that
[Music]
[Applause]